there's this former Republican
congressman named Joe Walsh he's really
a disgusting guy much like Steve King
big Tea Party guy is Joe Walsh when he
was in Congress used to have a radio
show where he would say horribly
inflammatory things he is now
apologizing apologizing for his role in
helping to get Donald Trump elected in
2016
he wrote a New York Times op-ed
yesterday where he said quote in mr.
Trump I see the worst and ugliest
iteration of views I expressed for the
better part of a decade to be sure I've
had my share of controversy on more than
one occasion I questioned mr. Obama's
truthfulness about his religion at times
I expressed hate for my political
opponents we now see where this can lead
there's no place in our politics for
personal attacks like that and I regret
making them so okay I mean this is good
Walsh is realizing how destructive and
terrible Trump has been he's realizing
how destructive and terrible some of the
things he did which are similar to the
personal type attacks that Donald Trump
makes how terrible those were but he
didn't just help elect Donald Trump this
guy's entire moral compass is completely
backwards he once tweeted if Trump loses
I'm grabbing my musket that's not a
personal attack that's actually a threat
of violence a specific threat of
violence from a prominent Republican he
said on Twitter quote I'll just say it
Sandy Hook parents your 15 minutes is up
against guy guest gun safety activists
coming out of the Sandy Hook shooting
and who even knows what he meant by that
I could give you a really long list but
the point is this guy wasn't just a
supporter of Trump in 2016 and he
regrets supporting Trump because Trump
has been bad or something like that he
was supporting Trump in the most toxic
and destructive way possible while
simultaneously being a completely
deplorable right winger so okay it's
good that he changed his mind about
Trump his point I guess is to encourage
a primary challenge against Trump he
tweeted
today quote why did I write this piece
two reasons first I wanted to make clear
that Donald Trump is unfit to be
President and he must be challenged in
the Republican primary and second I
wanted to apologize for the role I
played in helping to put an unfit con
man in the White House so I've said
before it's a problem in our society
when people become irredeemable and
we've actually when we talked to former
extremists last week I interviewed
former neo-nazi Frank mink he said one
of the things that helps get extremists
out of their views is becoming
redeemable being redeemable and being
reaccept advice aasaiya T when they
attempt to right the wrongs and move out
of their horrible extremist ideology
that lack of empathy is what often gets
extremists into extreme views in the
first place and so it's really important
that people don't become irredeemable to
society
and I agree with that right I mean we
need people to be redeemable in order to
encourage more people to reconsider
their actions at the same time he's
still a toxic Republican who doesn't
like Trump and who was so ignorant or
blinded by partisanship to a degree that
I guess he didn't realize the extent of
the damage that he was doing by
supporting Donald Trump good for him I
mean it's tough to own up the mistakes
if more people did it would be better
off as a society but this doesn't change
that Joe Walsh still would put elected
officials in power who want terrible
policy and who if they are allowed to do
what it is they want to do would be
hugely destructive in terms of the
direction of the country if it were up
to Joe Walsh we would have what a
slightly less insane less toxic
Republican as president that's not what
the left is looking for beyond the one
point of agreement that Trump has to go
so let's give him credit where he
deserves credit it's tough to say I made
a mistake it's tough to do it publicly
that's great at the same time let's not
pretend like now this guy is an ally of
some kind whose political views align
with ours
there's also another angle here the idea
being Republicans are simply realizing
that Trump is a losing ticket so it's
not that they're abandoning Trump
because they don't like Trump style tone
tenor or way of doing business they're
trying to get themselves
off of a sinking ship before it takes
them down so they're claiming that it's
moral grounds that have them objecting
to Donald Trump but really it's a lot of
them think Trump will lose in which case
this is actually even less genuine than
we believe it to be let me know what you
think I'm glad giving credit where
credit is due we just don't want to give
more credit than what is actually do